this is your task given to you by the  gods  i should not have to remind you again  and you should have been able to  retrieve the ball on your own  such a simple task a cop could have done  it  but why did you appear when you did not  before  your blood hitting the earth called me  it is the only way i can be summoned  really that's how it works how much  blood are we talking about here  you had one job and you managed to fail  at that  we need that ball we don't need any more  stupid useless children  hey and the ball has bonded to them now  bonded  [Music]  so impressive see  bonded to them the ball won't go  anywhere they don't want it to  so now you need them to come with you  you